the reason most people aren't successful
is they just can't control
themselves like that's it it's impulse
control they did this research study
that said that Ultra successful people
have three common traits number one is
they have a superiority complex they
think they're better than everybody they
think they can do bigger things second
they have crippling insecurity of not
being enough that one hits me and then
the third one is impulse control so they
know where they want to go they have a
way drive to not be a failure and they
stay focused on it because of impulse
control I guarantee you if you delayed
your ass for 5 years and you to provide
a value to people you'd have bigger
audience than you what to do
with but guess what no one's going to do
it and that's why most people aren't
successful